السباق لإطعام أمة في الأيام الأخيرة
من موسم الحصاد الصيفي لتونس ، تؤدي
حيلة روسيا الساخرة لاحتجاز
أكثر من 20 مليون طن من
الحبوب الأوكرانية كرهائن إلى أزمة غذائية هنا
في تونس ومعظم شمال إفريقيا ،
هل أنت قلق من أنها ستستمر لفترة طويلة-
تأثير المدى على
تونس ، لقد أثرت الحرب حقًا على كل من
المستهلك والإنتاج الزراعي لدينا في
الوقت الحالي ، يجب أن تصبح كل دولة
معتمدة على نفسها إذا لم يكن ذلك ممكنًا ، فإن
الأمور ستصبح صعبة للغاية ،
وهم يسعون جاهدين لزيادة هذا
الإنتاج وتغيير عادات المستهلكين
في الشمس  - مزارعو تونس المخبوزون يزرعون
القمح القاسي لصنع المعكرونة والكسكس ، ولكن بالنسبة
للقمح الطري ، فإن القمح الذي يصنع الخبز
التونسي يحصل على حوالي 60 منه من
أوكرانيا وروسيا ، أخبرني أحد المسؤولين
أنهم لن يتمكنوا أبدًا من تكوين
هذا الرقم هنا ليس في  خمس سنوات ولا
حتى في العاشرة من
القرن الماضي ، يقول هذا الأمر أنه لا يمكننا بيع ما تعطينا الحكومة إلا
ما يقوله إن
خبز الباجيت مدعوم من قبل
الحكومة بشكل كبير في
الديون  لا يستطيع إيسي بالكاد تحمل تكلفة الطحين المستورد من خارج أوكرانيا ، يتعلق الأمر بالبقاء اليومي عندما يشعر الناس بالجوع إنهم يتمردون ، كما يقول هنا إنهم يتعافون للتو من جائحة مطمع ساحق وعقد من عدم اليقين السياسي ، لم يكن من الممكن أن يأتي تأثير الحرب في أوكرانيا في وقت أسوأ